euh un autre enjeu qui est très
important c'est l'affirmation sommme
tout nouvelle de l'Union européenne
comme puissance il y a encore 5 ans
c'était une idée qui était relativement
tabou à Bruxelles d'affirmer que l'Union
était une puissance qui devait trouver
sa place dans le jeu international entre
les États-Unis la Russie et la Chine et
aujourd'hui il y a assez peu de gens
pour contester cette idée et donc là
aussi c'est une une chose qu'il faut un
petit peu mettre en musique l'idée de
l'Union européenne qui doit assurer sa
propre sécurité dans un monde qui est
devenu un peu plus dangereux et très
incertain si Monsieur Trump éait élu aux
États-Unis chaîne je pense que on va
devoir mener à nouveau une réflexion sur
la possibilité de s'en remettre
uniquement à l'OTAN pour assurer notre
notre sécurité donc il faut repenser un
petit peu l'Union quelle union
voulons-nous quelles institutions pour
faire fonctionner cette union comment
organiser l'élargissement sans brader
l'acquis communautaire et et les valeurs
de l'Union euh et comment faire en sorte
qu'une union à 35 reste fonctionnelle
dans ce contexte qui demande de la
réactivité et une certaine capacité à à
prendre des des initiatives donc c'est
dans ce contextelà que que Laurence Bau
et Alana lourman ont lancé cette cette
réflexion euh en nous demandant de
rester c'est très important uniquement
sur les institutions et pas sur les
politiques parce que tel est le mandat
qui est le leure en tant que membre du
Conseil Affaires général où on discute
des questions institutionnelles mais pas
des politiques publiques et il est
évident qu'il faut mener toute une autre
réflexion sur la réforme des politiques
de l'Union européennees de ses priorités
budgétaires si on veut réussir à penser
l'avenir de de l'Union